[Musique]
tout a commencé avec cette vidéo d'un
retraité de 85 ans piégé par le Français
Steven Moore à la Réunion
c'est pas votre sexe à chaque fois la
même technique un coup d'éclat avec
souvent une enquête ouverte et une
arrestation à la clé
86 ans vous rendez compte non mais c'est
incroyable alors qu'est Steven Moore
alors c'est un lanceur d'alerte sur la
pédocrinalité depuis que depuis quelques
années par contre j'aurais rebondir sur
quelque chose ce n'est pas lui qui a
diffusé la vidéo mais les médias locaux
nous ne faisons pas ça d'accord voilà
donc ça c'est important de dire bien sûr
et donc lui il avait commencé à mettre
en ligne un premier enfant virtuel donc
alicia est très vite cet enfant virtuel
a été contacté par des dizaines d'hommes
et du coup moi je les rejoins pour faire
pour faire la même chose et même constat
lorsque j'ai mis en ligne mon premier
profil d'enfant virtuel alors justement
donc votre méthode est simple vous créez
de faux profils de mineur sur les
réseaux sociaux et ensuite ça va très
très vite des mineurs de quel âge
alors moi c'était Lina 13 ans donc faut
comprendre que pour faire un profil
d'enfant il y a des règles il y a un
protocole pour pas faire de mise de
procédure donc on utilise les photos de
notre propre visage on applique un
filtre rajeunissant pour pas être accusé
des heures passant l'identité ou
d'atteindre son droit à l'image d'accord
ensuite les cybers prédateurs entrent en
contact avec nous donc c'est eux qui
font la première demande d'amis pas nous
pour pas être accusé d'incitation délit
ou de provocation dans les échanges dans
les repousses on dit tout de suite qu'on
a 12-13 ans et enfin il ne faut surtout
pas diffuser l'identité de l'auteur
ainsi que les échanges obtenus pour pas
être accusé d'atte à la vie privée donc
c'est très important de respecter ces
points là pour pas faire de Visio
procédure et donc vous leur dites tout
de suite que vous avez vraiment 13 ans
etc voilà donc c'est c'est important
alors
vous avez rapidement des demandes d'amis
des messages très vite
d'homme
la plupart sont des hommes d'accord de
quel âge
selon la loi ça commence à 18 ans
jusqu'à 85 ans
certains sont immédiatement dans le
biguite ou pire ou pas du tout oui en
fait nous on les classes dans deux
catégories distinctes donc on a ce que
j'appelle les pervers donc c'est ceux
qui vont explicitement parler de
sexualité ou de quelques lignes qui vont
faire des propositions sexuelles montrer
des photos de leur sexe en érection se
masturber derrière l'écran et les faux
anges gardiens qui eux vont être dans
une manipulation ça va prendre des
semaines et des mois mais toujours la
même chose ils veulent des photos nues
de l'enfant ils vont se masturber aussi
envoyer des vidéos pornographiques voir
zoophiles aussi des fois donc ça va très
très loin
excusez-moi mais c'est mec de 86 ans
faut vraiment être un tarin excusez-moi
ces personnes elles pensent réellement
donc parler à une
ah oui clairement puisqu'on répète l'âge
dans la conversation
quand ils nous envoient une photo de
leur sexe on le repose en disant mais
pourquoi tu fais ça moi ça me dégoûte
j'ai que 12 ans je te rappelle mais non
tu dois apprendre tu es une grande fille
ils évitent même Cyril d'écrire pendant
les périodes scolaires pour bien montrer
que vous êtes jeune c'est ça quand vous
vous écrivez
à des heures auxquelles n'importe quel
enfant est connecté donc après l'école
le mercredi après-midi les week-end et
les vacances scolaires tout à fait alors
on a des screens de conversation nous
avons choisi de pas mettre les plus
trashiens bien entendu vous allez voir
que c'est terrible voilà je dis pas tu
les caresses devant en prenant la douche
je les lave comme tout le monde ça te
fait quoi quand tu les caresses pourquoi
non mais c'est un
je vous ai donné les plus soft
regardez-moi ces abrutis
bon voilà donc on va revoir ils
utilisent d'utiliser différentes
méthodes sur les réseaux sociaux pour
vous faire passer pour des jeunes
mineurs c'est notamment une méthode pour
la voix regardez
quand un individu insiste pour voir ou
entendre l'enfant le collectif a mis en
place une base de données de voix pour
le garder dans ses filets
ils ont 83 réponses types
on a une membre de l'équipe une adulte
bien évidemment qui a le pouvoir d'avoir
une voix enfantine et en fait elle nous
a fait plusieurs phrases qu'on se serait
uniquement en cas d'urgence
dans ce cas là ce sont les magistrats
qui sont hors la loi si ils condamnent
les individus sur la base de nos
éléments d'accord donc vous continuez
bien sûr et ça fonctionne d'accord donc
vous avez aujourd'hui vous risquez rien
ah non
protéger pour pas ils sont obligés de
changer leur visage de faire attention
que ce soit eux qui aille faire les
choses ils sont obligés de se protéger
eux sinon ils sont hors la loi et là on
leur dit encore non ce que vous faites
vous êtes hors la loi la cellule qui
s'occupe de la pédocriminalité il y a
combien il doit y avoir 30 ou 40
personnes qui s'occupent pour des
millions de de pédophiles qui traînent
c'est pas assez en fait on n'abandonne
pas les moyens en fait on donne pas les
moyens pour arrêter la pédocrinalité il
y a vraiment pas assez c'est une cellule
qui s'occupe pas la foi de pédocrinalité
et aussi de trafic de drogue ou je sais
pas quoi c'est la même cellule qui
s'occupe de ça donc faut s'occuper du
trafic de drogue des gens qui fraudent
je ne sais quoi et de la pédocrinalité
exploser avec les c'est pas possible
alors c'est pas positif c'est de piéger
c'est pédophiles lorsqu'il propose des
rendez-vous au faux mineurs regardez le
profil d'un de ses prédateurs regarde
leur cible est un homme qui drague un
enfant jade 12 ans sans savoir que c'est
un faux profil de Neila donc en fait tu
veux absolument faire un bébé avec
l'enfant donc qu'elle lui répond que
c'est pas possible il lui dit je vais te
forcer alors
te baiser jusqu'à un bébé un bébé ou je
te tue
ok je te tue je savais que faire ta
première fois c'est de détournement sur
mineur donc un viol il use le terme viol
quoi donc il sait qu'il est hors-la-loi
il assume en fait
c'est incroyable
vous expliquer que lorsque vous faites
ces profils c'est à peine parfois
quelques minutes avant que ce type
n'arrive c'est donc c'est vraiment
extrêmement flippant pour les pour les
parents quand ils imaginent que leurs
enfants parce qu'on n'est pas derrière
les les réseaux sociaux de des enfants
et des plus jeunes et aujourd'hui les
plus jeunes même si on dit qu'on n'a pas
le droit de s'inscrire à moins de 16 ans
sur les réseaux sociaux on sait bien
qu'à 10 11 12 ans ils sont déjà sur les
réseaux
sur les réseaux sociaux ils sont
derrière les gens en ligne en fait du
moment qu'il y a moyen de chat ils sont
là et beaucoup se font passer pour des
enfants eux-mêmes donc faut vraiment
instaurer un dialogue avec son enfant il
faut faire de la prévention auprès des
parents aussi donc
en regardant vos publications vous avez
expliqué qu'un enfant le chiffre m'a
effrayé un enfant sur 10 va être une
cible sexuelle c'est à dire c'est
carrément une cible sexuelle c'est même
pas être confronté à va être ciblé par
des prédateurs 10% des enfants qui
utilisent Internet sont ciblés par les
utilisateurs c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable comme chiffre et vous
expliquer aussi qu'il y a de plus en
plus de jeunes de jeunes adultes qui
vont vouloir commettre des actes
pédophiles ou en tout cas cibler les
enfants à quoi c'est dû ça alors pour
moi c'est dû à la génération porno
littéralement que pour des adultes qui
tombent dans dans la pornographie très
tôt qui sont dépendants qui vont
commencer par de la pornographie soft
ensuite un petit peu plus trash ensuite
ils vont tomber dans la zoophilie et
ensuite ils vont tomber dans la
pédopornographie on a énormément de
prédateurs sexuels qui nous contactent
qui ont entre 20 et 25 ans qui sont déjà
accro à la pédopornographie
qu'est ce qui va se passer de
comment vont évoluer ces personnes là
dans 10-15 ans alors quand le
rendez-vous est fixé les membres du
Mouvement s'y rendre pour le piéger vous
allez voir que certains prédateurs n'ont
pas forcément de regret regarder la
vidéo d'une arrestation
pourquoi vous justement vous prenez pour
des filles de 12 ans 13 ans vous avez 22
ans vous croyez ça normal
face aux évidences l'homme essaye de
fuir
impensable pour maths
j'ai les screen donc ne dites pas que ne
dites pas que c'est pour votre petit
frère
voilà
[Musique]
la base c'est pas votre c'est pas vos
métiers en fait les personnes je suis
femme de ménage dans la vie et donc il y
a des mamans il y a des papas comment
est-ce que émotionnellement vous faites
le soir pour vous retirer de tout ça
parce que toute la journée vous avez
vous avez vrai quoi au départ quand on a
commencé effectivement c'était difficile
c'était une activité qui prenait
énormément de temps on voyait des choses
horribles au quotidien et puis à force
on va dire que on va dire qu'on
s'habitue à avoir l'horreur en fait et
si des gens ont envie de rentrer dans
votre dans votre team et de faire partie
parce que je pense plus on est non plus
on est nombreux plus on arrivera à
fouiller alors après on peut pas on peut
pas prendre tout le monde donc déjà pour
rentrer chez nous il y a quand même
beaucoup de conditions mais en décembre
2019 on a créé un mouvement dans le sens
où on a permis la création plusieurs
collectifs et d'associations qui
utilisent notre méthode qui ont des
résultats aussi et ce mouvement réuni
plus ces résultats de notre groupe on
est à plus de 200 arrestations
c'est quand on vous entend de penser
qu'on peut vous reprocher à vivre de
procédure dans ce que vous faites ça me
paraît allusion on devrait en fait on
devrait vous remercier je pense que
l'État devrait vous donner une médaille
même travailler avec vous c'est
invraisemblable que vous risquez vous
d'être pratiquement plus puni que c'est
salopards qui font des vidéos
c'est aberrant je trouve ça je trouve ça
scandaleux et quand j'entends le
ministre la justice qui dit chacun à sa
place excuse-moi monsieur le ministre
c'est la vôtre c'est de protéger nos
enfants et et c'est pas ces gens-là en
théorie donc ça me ça me met ça me
choque vraiment profondément c'est un
scandale
alors il faut expliquer quand même que
si le ministre continue de vociférer et
si les autorités les hautes autorités
policières vous ont critiqué au niveau
du travail concret ça se passe beaucoup
mieux c'est-à-dire qu'il y a beaucoup de
policiers et de gendarmes qui vous
remercie de votre travail comme vous
l'avez dit vous le publiez pas vous
envoyer tout de suite les documents vous
avez un cadre juridique blindé j'ai
regardé totalement irréprochable donc
vous vous aidez vous n'êtes pas des
auxiliaires vous n'êtes pas des
justiciers mais vous travaillez et puis
après vous laissez les autorités prendre
le relais ça vient ça votre méthode
c'est exactement ça
j'étais dans mes pensées parce que je me
disais qu'évidemment pourrait nous
reprocher de dire si on fait la
publicité à ce que ce que fait cette
dame on va inciter aussi les gens à
jouer les enquêteurs et les policiers et
que si ça ça se ça se généralise ça va
être un joli bordel aussi encore une
fois je répète à la réunion de
copropriété de tout à l'heure quand tout
le monde donne son avis si tu veux
que vous lui expliquez aussi comment
vous en profil justement quand je
connais les clés c'est pour pas que le
premier individu qui veut le faire fasse
n'importe quoi et qui se retrouve à la
place de l'accusé